I was gonna say uh you've obviously had
some experiences with Hove who's another
Brooklyn Legend what was your
experiences coming up and and being
around Jay-Z
I mean Jay's the goat to me I agree he's
done it I think he's the guy yeah he's
the goal he deserves all the accolades
at this point and I salute him properly
but you know I've even always followed
his music you know I admired his skills
his style everything about him the
evolution yep yep and everything he's
become right now I stand proud to say
that's Brooklyn baby
um hope was actually one of the people
interested in doing the low life story
like most you know the sit downs we have
had were based around doing this film or
this series or whatever it's supposed to
be but I mean all my interactions with
him were mostly me trying to battle him
like trying to pull him out to battle me
and things like that so I got to a point
one day where instead of asking him I
just spit at him
so he had to respond and you know I
could tell this story forever because
you know being who he is not many people
could say they actually would step to
Jay and attempt to battle you know
because I'm a monster with it my punch
lines are the truth and all of that but
do you recall which year that happened
uh 96 wow so that's like Reasonable
Doubt Reasonable Doubt error when he had
Rockefeller offices like downtown so I
one day I was demo shopping
so when I made my first demo I had my
first five songs from a four track you
know I had a bio with a with a head shot
and I probably had 50 packages in my
truck that day and I went to Def Jam I
put one on everybody's desk I went to
the source I spit for the unsigned hype
they gave me the collar and then I went
to Rockefeller and with the day I went
there to just to take my my package
Jay-Z was actually in the office and
they called them out to come see me so
I'm like he knew who I was and all that
because I also worked at MTV for years
and most of the artists that will come
to MTV to do whatever work I would step
to them the battle and that's where I
used to approach jay most of the time I
even approached them at the Video Music
Awards One Time crazy yeah like what's
up we're going battle what's up you know
I would do that constantly anytime I
seen them that's so crazy to think well
first of all how did that go when he he
spit back oh nah he would always be like
you're not ready so you wrapped you spit
at him not those times only the last
time was I didn't ask him because every
other time he just brushed me off right
and he's not trying to hear me so I
guess he didn't know what I possessed so
that last time he found out yeah so he
had to spit back because my rhyme also
was something that was kind of
particular going against everything he
says you know that it was against the
drug rap the my Rolex in Lexington Texas
I don't want to hear that either you
know I was on it like that but he
definitely came back strong you know he
definitely spit he rode the elevator
with me down and we was on there getting
busy do you uh do you remember any of
your rhyme from that elevator ride the
ROMs you about to hear nevertheless of
my own this is for you young MC's oh my
how have you grown you got bigger better
stronger and much faster I remember when
you were smaller slower with a speech
impediment impediment and had asthma you
a comedian when you started doing stand
up and when you come up with all these
[__] stupid answers your Rhymes would
be cute if you wrote them on a pad that
was pink when MC's think they Above the
Rim I make them realize they really
below the sink before we battle check it
out I got these rules you can't say nine
times spine all that [__] is preschool
you could talk about Coke deliveries
that would never be here [__] like that
but I not I'm I'm bugging that I
actually remember that [__] right now
because it was also an acapella that I
put on that Brooklyn Hard Rock single I
had one acapella to go with it and that
was the acapella that I spit at Jay that
day Jesus that's crazy man shout out to
Hove so we sh we will be seeing the low
life story in some form or fashion
on many forms because my my you know
aspect and my part of the story is only
one camera angle right there's so many
stories there's so many lowlifes that
there's so many different stories
involved this so the story you're gonna
see is just from my perspective but I'm
sure there will be other perspectives
coming into play at a point in time I
because I think like I always hear about
the hip-hop police back then obviously
late 80s 90s
heavy Mafia times in New York City uh
that's kind of like the peak of like
when the mafia kind of started to end I
guess was the early 90s were you guys
like looked at as like a criminal
organization at a certain point in time
NYPD of course so it was in the books
one of one of my good friends worked at
uh
a youth incarcerated center right and he
sent me a card one time he sent me a
photo of a card that when you come into
the juvenile system you had to fill out
this card and it asked you which gang
are you a part of and low life was one
of the boxes of the options to check off
right who would actually fill that out
honestly like let's just admit to being
in a gang on this a juvenile youth wants
it to be known he wants that critics
because when he walks into that he wants
people to know his gang affiliation with
pride and you know I know that from
being a dumb juvenile youth as well so
it's crazy man well I can't wait to see
whatever comes out of of the meeting is
coming out uh the out is the album
already out did it come out yeah those
illustrators on All Digital platforms I
got features on there me and smooth The
Hustler got a joint called Brownsville
Legends I got the rockness monster and
ug from seller dwellers we got a song
called lows and cons basically telling
the low life and decepticon relationship
because everybody always thought like we
was against each other you know we was
Ops but that wasn't in Brownsville that
wasn't the case maybe in other areas
because in Brownsville we was all family
low lights and Decepticons we actually
lived in the same neighborhood what are
the Decepticons you know there was a
bunch of dudes on the train beating
people up with hammers man like the
[__] Home Tool Hammers and robbing
everybody for walkmans and but they
would be on the subway system like
hundreds of [__] coming through
that's like what you always hear like
because when you cause like I never
lived in New York I think the first time
I went to New York was 2013.
and
you hear about this crazy crime wave
that was happening and then you hear
that Giuliani cleaned it up I guess
cleaned it up and did it was it like a
thing when he became mayor you really
noticed [__] [__] change was you know
unexplainable you know he imposed the
quality of life law and remember in New
York City you get on the subway with
your liquor bottle your beer bottle
Giuliani stop that that helped because
[__] was on the train drunk Wilding
you know there was all kind of [__]
going on in New York City but he
definitely cleaned it up I believe it's
back to being the dirty New Yorker once
was even Times Square that got cleaned
up you know I was just in Times Square a
while ago so it was wow now it's back to
the dude the dirty Deuce days you know I
mean there's all kind of scammers out
Bootleggers the three-car Molly dude is
back oh my God the dude with the little
boy oh yeah the cap dude yo when I seen
that recently I've seen that